some of our guy I was talking about
nobody was born a martial artist when I
was asking some top people about what
makes a special person you know and then
well these people like the Great's that
we talk about the gand is the ascendancy
in Aikido there's some of many in the
martial art world that would look we we
pose these masters beyond we always put
them beyond him being a human but
they're not everybody's a human being
they pursue them are someone delve so
deep almost fanatical the Aikido that I
chose was because I wanted one that
worked it doesn't matter about whether
it works as a martial art or not at the
time when I was thinking about this but
I needed to work I need but if
somebody's going to a technique on me I
want them to know that the technique can
be achieved and when I become a black
male my first day I still going to
London for classes my teacher is slowly
between first and second and because I
used to travel all the way there laughs
they laughed back to do the owner of
class every Sunday and my family
tolerated a lot as well other time
I was determined to go to the best and
learn from the best
between first and second and place
slowly stop using me and these were
fifth down master's knobs on your first
and going towards second and I couldn't
understand why stop using me I thought
was because I was a black male they
would be using lower grades to develop
them and bring them on
so I lost my friend one day who's also
being used but he was same level but
they were still using him he's I don't
suppose they struggled with you Tony
you're getting too powerful yourself and
they can't do the techniques on you
anymore miss I felt very daunting
because I love the place I love my
teachers I love the people I trained
with and I didn't want to stop during
the art but where could I go so I
studied in a few places in Europe and
the top masters some Japanese and I
found that even though they were very
good they could do much more than the
British teachers I had
but there was nothing that blew me away
nothing might may think they made that
so easy but that I would follow them
another time there were some books just
come out in 1973 and in 1975 I had my
first credit card and I was able to buy
these books and some silly film and
these films with books were of
saitou-san see the man lined up
following and I used to cop play the
films that night go outside in my back
garden and I didn't try to perform them
ken or Joe work though I saw my dick
backwards and forwards until I got it
and being dyslexic it takes us a lot
longer to understand it than some people
I do think the advantage that dyslexic
people have even though there's lots of
variants on dyslexia my particular one
was I didn't get it straight away if I
went on a seminar I would come back I
could show it to one of the other people
whether they on the blackout's in like a
club what we done and within a few
minutes they had it better than I had in
long I was one on the seminar and it was
very disheartening and even paid to go
but three weeks later
I was far better than them so even
though we have to work hard at it
there's it goes in and it goes in deep
so my friend emigrated to New Zealand
and oh my god I can't remember a letter
now and he said all your teachers coming
here has just returned up from the
railways
he's never got to start traveling the
world teaching seminars if you want to
come work for you all you got to do is
follow on the flow the flight ticket I
jumped on the chance some florist the
world's in New Zealand met situs NC he
heard that some read flown all the way
to England that straightaway caught me
in the good books he said do you have a
camera I said we'll have a cine camera
and he told everybody else no photos if
you want to learn you train on the man
you learn from the manual men work but
for me he allowed me to accept buyers
but film as you can so I bought cine
film and I filmed have allowed me to
film parts of the seminar straight away
upper I made enemies it's not enemies in
the way that you would think of an enemy
but made an enemy because I was the only
one allowed to film and all the others
were told they couldn't so that puts you
as a loner and I found this way of I
traveled in the world
he was always greeted me because I would
he know always would travel it's I'm not
saying this to make me sell big or
anything by I disarmed good quality
Aikido I grabbed him they called me out
I grabbed him he looked of me because I
didn't only grab him may have moved him
he staggered a little
by crowd his rest he looked at me he
looked at class and said this man is the
strongest man on this tatami
I felt so big so proud he then followed
it by if he doesn't learn to lose this
strength he will never understand I send
his Aikido I win inside the size of a
mouse and for the next 20 years I'm sure
it was perhaps even longer but but I
know for at least the next 10 to 20
years every tell him if I trained I kept
thinking I must not use strength
I must not be a strength and in the next
segment I'm going to talk about why I
believe the difference between the
aikikai style and the alarmist are the
most important parts are what will make
your Aikido strong and what will it make
it work you know you don't have to make
it work but surely inside your heart you
want to know that the art you're doing
whatever martial I are doing you would
want to know that it's true accurate and
if it was to be used it would work and
this is why to me I could I such a bad
name in the world for not working and we
will be discussing this in the next
segment
thank you don't forget to leave your
messages or your comments